I hate complaining this advice is for
the complainers I'm not upset with you
if you play video games all day or
watching Netflix all night I'm mad at
you if you're doing that and you're
baffled why you're not making more money
and living your dream if you're happy
and content you've won but if you're
complaining it means you haven't won yet
and you should stop complaining and do
something about it instead so what I
look to someone I look up to most in the
world tied with you dad is my mother
hands down gotta make dad feel oh god oh
yeah don't be mad hands down one of the
most intriguing thing about my mother is
her inability to complain it's probably
one of my favorite traits that she's
passed down to me I find it incredibly
attractive and as a quality I adore in
my wife as well it's even something I
try to instill in my children because I
think complaining is ugly personally I
don't complain if you look at my tweets
historically maybe there's two or three
complaints you'll never catch me
complaining about well you know what I
want to put in there except for the New
York Jets which I complain a lot you'll
never catch me
complaining about not seeing my kids
enough or not having enough leisure time
because if I've had an issue with those
things I would do something about it
there's no shifting into the complaining
zone when I warrant or you know what
there's an important point or or I would
recognize that I have the ability to do
something about it because that's the
part there's no shifting into the
complains in when I encounter an issue
I'm not happy with
I'm very put your head down when it
comes to problem-solving for me it's
about assessing the problem figuring it
out and then going directly back on the
offense complaining is defense to me the
only thing you're to me the only thing
you are that is acceptable to complain
about are the things you can't control
that the unfortunate health of yourself
or your loved ones or some other
unforeseen tragedies I want to clarify
just to set the record straight if
you're complaining about anything
then you need to audit yourself you
can't just go watch house of cards you
can't play ball all day you can't go to
valet shows you got to work to fix it
there I want you add stuff yep um you
can't sit there and complain and you
can't sit there and ponder what if I had
rich parents I grew up in a better
neighborhood I made that
investment I went to that school you got
to work to fix it there are so many
people reading this right now who are
complaining people love to complain
because it's easy executing to fix those
problems on the other hand it's hard
look I understand that many of you have
student loans and mortgages and a rough
time working two jobs while trying to
spend time with your family but are you
happy if you are then you've won because
you don't actually have anything to
complain about the real problem is that
there are so many millions of people who
are unhappy and are just sitting around
complaining playing Madden for hours and
not actually trying to solve the very
things they're complaining about and I
want to paint a couple more pictures
playing Madden for hours , or having
their 18th of dinner with their other
complaining friend and complaining back
and forth to each other like one big
goddamn [ __ ] game of seesaw
complaining but keep the [ __ ] part up
in today's world we're so ingrained to
expect instant gratification friends
right now who like literally have like
that one or two person in their lives
and like that's their entire friendship
their entire friendship is predicated on
they go out every six weeks and they
literally ping-pong back and forth about
how much they hate their sister-in-law
and how much they got screwed by their
mom right no it's enable no it's not
cathartic it's enabling like it since
enabling the bad bit like friends have
people have yeah I mean listen everybody
should dump their stress out
I believe in therapy I believe in a
great HR department I believe in all
that stuff but like but like it's
actually enable meant it's like people
have friendships predicated on the
enablement of negativity yeah I guess
you know what dude that's the blood I
said I bet that is how I set it up exact
it is good in today's world were so
ingrained to expect instant
gratification and that our problems by
the way real quick on the counter point
to your point like my mom is absolutely
the person that what once every three
years where I have to dump something
that's where I go and she to me so it
can be the bet foundation of a great
friendship but I'm telling you like this
is like I've been like observing like
all this traveling has allowed me to not
only peep at people's phones but like
[ __ ] it's unbelievable if you like
really get your nose enos into
somebody's conversation like an ungodly
amount of percentages I got screwed it's
like everybody got screwed including by
the way I got screwed I got into a rich
family and I'm not that hungry and I
don't know what it's like and my parents
spoiled me too much I mean like
literally you could make up anything for
anything one with nothing complain
born with everything complain all right
guy patience is real and so is hard work
sometimes that hard work might not even
be as terrible as you think need money
we live in a 24/7 world where you can
make money in your underwear think about
it if there's one thing I want you to
learn from reading this it's that
complaining has zero value looking at
the negative seeing the glass as
half-empty in completing are some of the
biggest waste of time a human being can
engage in instead tackle the problem
head-on assess it see what you can do
about it and then do just that what was
me is truly one of the biggest things
that can stand in the way of success
both professionally and personally love
it uh when we entitle a complaint about
complaining waiting yeah I don't know we
did we couldn't think of it yeah I love
that one of the few things that guy want
it again one of the few how about one of
the few things I complain about
complaining got it yeah um my favorite
copy and this is um if there's truly one
move that all if there's truly one move
that I've seen that's held back my
friends and families my friends
contemporaries and family it's
complaining please read this article
carefully and end and and then a whole
separate thing and make sure that I
actually leave it at that look at that
I'm PSU PSU we have completing his
defense completing is unattractive
complaining is easy executing is hard if
you're happy complaining is easy
executing is hard
say yours nice Congrats are we done yeah
cool now - guys this is this is like we
need to title this like content on
content on content the infrastructure of
a true strategy look I'm so proud of
what is just transpiring here just hit
me as I turn to you guys I've created a
couple of pillars right this complaining
was I guess I don't know part of a
dailyvee or an episode of were just a
bunch of rights so like the thought of
having daily be and the askgaryvee show
that we're about the film and we were
about to bend I said Stefan put the
camera on this this is literally in
emotion the strategy which is when you
have something at the top and this is
something all of you need to think about
especially if we start allocating
resources to it because for seven or
eight years I made content by myself
there was not all of these attractive
and smart people it was just me doing my
thing but if you're lucky enough to take
the next step in so many of you have
emailed me and said that you want to
have your d-roc you want to have your
India you've got dollars
you realize taking home an extra $40,000
might not be worth it if you want to
make more money in long term you want to
start investing my number one thing is I
don't think that I talk enough about my
strategies I kind of talk about my work
ethic and I don't talk enough about my
brain this is something I brought up
like a year or two ago and then do
anything about it so here I am this is
strategy me understanding that if I made
an investment two core pillars the
askgaryvee show and dailyvee that then i
could empower my team to consume that
see what is the content the moment and
then create content around it so what
you just saw you've heard me talk about
but this is how we do it usually on the
phone because I'm traveling a bunch but
this is you just saw this is how an
articles made all those words are things
that I've said synthesized by the team
down with grammar and commas and some
leeway then you see I listen I tweak it
I alter it we come up with copy we come
up with the picture I'll put on
Instagram links to it we come up with
the titles and the Facebook copy what's
even more crazy is that is our normal
content on content creation look what
just happened I just made a third piece
of content the content of the show and
all the content creating the article now
I'm creating this content this is meta
meta meta meta cubed not even squared so
what you just saw is my attempt to
continue to create new content for you
guys this is kind of a glimpse into our
process of how we take what we do in the
show and turn it into articles so men
me of the big podcasters out there that
I've been on the shows of when I audit
their content right Pat Flynn Lois house
of the you know you know art of charm
they're not producing enough in my
opinion articles that they could be
doing all day long all my interviews
alone could have been for medium pieces
one clip could have been a SoundCloud
clip another clip of my audio for three
minutes could have been turned with some
visual on top of it and so I believe
that there are clearly two to seven mean
and that's such an arbitrary number but
enormous amounts of content that are
coming from the big piece of content
that sits on the top and it's the
hacking of the mothership content into
micro content and even if you look at
gif even though I know people want to
call we're stumbled on this Jeff if you
look a gift for jiff however you want to
call it structure right almost all that
content comes from bigger pieces of
media that was just like chopped funny
and a lot of times look look in the
success of all our content of Facebook
our 20 million organic reach to videos
that we've had in the last well actually
one was made for it
my little college ramp but the other one
was a minute 30 for my Shaw interview
like there is so much more opportunity
and there's not an accident behind the
fact that my Facebook fan page has gone
from 500 to 700 25,000 fans literally in
the last three weeks let's put that into
context all the years five six seven to
get the five hundo and the last three
weeks to grow 50% it's our understanding
of how do we do video content captioned
properly and all stuff like this that
has led the way so I hope you enjoyed a
little look behind the curtain I hope
you take a step back and think about hmm
I'm doing this one thing or hmmm how do
I create a weekly podcast a daily video
show that can lead to micro content to
other pieces of content what I would
call sawdust fascinated by sawdust the
byproducts of what you do right the
byproduct of cutting two by fours leads
to sawdust somebody realized one day let
me package that up and sell it I'm a
fascinated fascinated by that figure it
out for yourself cool alright cool show